after 10 years Apple has finally updated
the design of their MacBook Air with the
brand new 2018 model and from the looks
of it it's the best choice if you're
trying to buy an entry-level MacBook
right well not exactly the new MacBook
Air has some pretty serious shortcomings
compared to last year's 13-inch MacBook
Pro which is now on sale for $100 off
for a limited time on B&H so it's the
exact same price as the new MacBook Air
we think the 2017 MacBook Pro is the
better choice but of course both laptops
have their strengths so let's take a
look at what the pro does better first
even though the new MacBook Air finally
has a Retina display with the same
resolution that the pro has it's
actually much worse the new air is rated
at 300 nits of brightness but laptop mag
measured only 234 and comparison the
2017 MacBook Pro is rated at 500 nits
and it measured in at 458 nits that's
almost twice as bright you can see both
laptops at maximum brightness and the
difference is pretty clear not only that
but the MacBook Pro supports p-3 wide
color gamut so it's much more color
accurate than the new air another
drawback to the new air is the lack of
performance the pro scored quite a bit
better in Geekbench for CPU tests and we
saw the same thing in Cinebench r15 CPU
tests as well for graphics the pro was
50% faster in Geekbench 4 and also
faster in Cinebench as graphics tests
now I know that's why it's called the
pro but you can buy the pro for
literally the same exact price as the
air also the new MacBook Air only comes
with a 30 watt power adapter while the
pro comes with a 61 watt power adapter
so the battery on the pro should charge
almost twice as fast the trackpad on the
MacBook Pro is also significantly larger
even though the keyboards are
practically the same size so you've got
more room to navigate one thing we
notice is that the speakers on the 2017
pro are actually better than the ones on
the new air just listen for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
based on everything we've compared so
far the MacBook Pro looks like the
obvious choice but now let's talk about
some of the ways the MacBook Air is
better the air is rated at 12 hours of
battery life while the pro only gets 10
it's also more portable
weighing in at 2.7 5 pounds a quarter of
a pound less than the pro even though
they're basically the same size if you
look at them from above
the air definitely looks thinner from
the side thanks to the wet shape
interestingly the air is slightly
thicker at the wide end but much thinner
near the front the MacBook Pros front
edge tends to dig into your wrist
after long typing sessions but the air
actually slopes downward so it's much
more comfortable to type on not only
that but the air has updated third
generation butterfly keys that include a
silicone barrier to protect the key
switches from debris which caused issues
with a rare number of older junky boards
like on the 2017 macbook pro the air
also gets such ID which is really nice
for logging into your account and buying
things with Apple pay the probe doesn't
get that the air also comes with Apple's
new t2 chip which enables hey Siri
support and takes care of a lot of tasks
like automatic file encryption which
will help it stay future-proof for years
to come however there's been a lot of
backlash over it with many people
complaining that the teach you chip
blocks third-party shops from doing
repairs on it but to me it's not a big
deal at all so which one should you buy
well if you care about performance
especially graphics performance then
definitely buy the pro and if you use
your macbook outside or constantly set
your brightness of the Macs then buy the
pro if you're big on portability
honestly there's not much of a
difference they'll both still fit in the
same carrying case and you won't really
notice a difference in weight if you
absolutely must get the best battery
life then the air is the obvious choice
and if you do tons of typing every day
then the air will be more comfortable
but Ioana macbook pro and the edge
really doesn't bother me and I do love
the larger trackpad on the pro as well
another plus for the air is that the
keyboard will be more reliable thanks to
the silicone barrier and if you love
having loud and clear speakers the pro
ones their touch ID is nice but I
honestly
think it'll be a big enough deal to
affect someone's decision the teacher
chip is nice but I don't think it's a
big deal either and I basically never
use the hey Siri function on my 2018
MacBook Pro so if you're still having a
hard time deciding which model to buy
tally up all the things I mentioned and
whether they're important to you or not
and then just buy the one that gets the
most points we've got links to both in
the video description including the link
to the hundred dollars off MacBook Pro
sale but it's only for a limited time so
make your decision quick so thanks for
watching guys and make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on more videos
like this one